how long have you been in a cult what's
it like to be a Chia human you look like
you could stick your finger in a socket
without having stuck your finger in a
socket I volunteered to let a comedian
heckle me all day tomorrow he's gonna
come to my house he's gonna wake me up
he's gonna spend all day with me I'm
kind of looking forward to it cuz I like
company but I also feel like it might
get really annoying especially his jokes
are bad my name is Jay Chris Newberg and
I've been a comedian for 18 years
throughout my career I've been heckled
from time to time but I've never had the
joy and pleasure of heckling someone
back I volunteered to do this because I
think I have really thick skin and I
like good comedy I imagine he'll just be
like observing what I do and making fun
of it I can't imagine it can get that
personal because how would he know
anything about me I've never met this
guy I've done some extensive research on
Jordan
I've looked online in his Facebook and
Instagram and Twitter profiles I've
talked to his friends I've talked to his
coworkers I've talked to his
ex-girlfriend coming at him I'm not
really sure how I'm going to feel
because I hate everything hecklers
represent the tried of me but I'm not a
mean person
[ __ ] him it's 7:50 3 in the morning I
found Jordan's place I'm with Kelly
she's in producer buzzing she's gonna be
following me we're outside his apartment
it's pretty good so far so pretty dirty
I don't understand the science of this
like decor like what girl doesn't come
in here see this and then just leap
right off the balcony here's Jordan
killing it from when he played a young
carrot top I wonder which one of those
socks are his girlfriend hey buddy super
excited to be here with the third
baseman of the Los Angeles Dodgers look
in the mirror buddy so what's it like to
be the body double for sadness people do
so I heard you and your girlfriend just
broke up true good for her
dan getting some in deep yeah you're
putting on your girlfriends you'll
understand later
how long have you played bass for
Mumford and Sons you're flossing on the
day that you're going to the dentist
isn't that like cleaning your house
before you have a cleaning lady come
over which obviously has never happened
so you're putting a product in right now
that's cool how long have you been a
before model you're like the most
handsome of all the Keebler elves we're
going to the dentist you gonna let them
drill yeah well hopefully not hopefully
minimal poking that's cool that was my
nickname in high school do you find it
you're on tinder most of the time during
sex like what are your favorite dating
app tinder is the tried and true what's
your opening line usually on tinder I
don't use repeat opening lines
I used the profiles what was the your
favorite theme ever used man had a
really good one recently it didn't get a
response and I was bummed about her
profile just said I like people places
and things and I said what you got
against adjectives they probably have
very nice things to say about you
I thought it's weird that that didn't
get a response so do you still talk to
Harry Potter do you get sad when some of
your personalities won't talk to you
would you [ __ ] yourself for money you
suck at parking so I've got my first
break from getting heckled and so far he
hasn't gotten under my skin a nice guy I
like him you're doing so good Jordan
hopefully they'll give you a little
plaque
why'd you ever lunch I had like a
chicken PETA thing it's so hard to be
mean to you it's just so hard because
it's like everything that you do is just
nice like there's nothing weird about
having a chicken pita for lunch I'm at
Jordan's desk now at BuzzFeed so
seriously what happens in the finale of
Game of Thrones yeah you know we're not
allowed I'm here also with destiny his
his desk neighbor
what's the bike being around Jordan all
day you know I said Jordan getting ready
to go down to the Laugh Factory from the
den I'm gonna get on stage do some jokes
and Jordan there's gonna heckle me like
all day hey what's up what's going I'm
in pretty good shape I'm in really good
spirits I've lost a lot of weight ever
since I quit have this shirt you picked
did you just pick up the first t-shirt
off the floor that you'd already worn
like three times and decide that's the
shirt for my set well yes actually
that's what I did I decided that I asked
this girl out once and she was like all
right cool but I want you to know one
thing I'm an a I was like all right
that's cool then you can drive because
I'm gonna get hammered I bet she still
didn't text me back you ever notice
that's sitting down and standing up
sounds a lot like sex cuz you're always
like oh my god
it makes sense that you have no idea
what sex sounds like aren't you sitting
in a booth alone yeah I just childproof
my house and by that I mean I purchase
condoms
funny Joe you're all that not laughing
at your [ __ ] joke I definitely think
that he should answer that first because
he knew all these things about me and we
started like digging at them I felt like
a certain closeness like oh this person
knows me and then throughout the day
spending the day together I felt like we
we sort of had a mutual understanding
that we're both going through this
experience together I think the most
frustrating thing about heckling and
nice guy is you kind of feel like an
a-hole because you don't really mean it
it's like here's this nice person who's
just going about their day that's Dennis
and I'm like aha you suck
I would definitely hang out with you
yeah like I think that'd be fun I would
do it as long as I didn't have to come
to your apartment
[Music]